274 millions de personnes ont le
français comme langue maternelle ou
langue d'usagé ce qui en fait la
cinquième langue la plus parlée du monde
derrière le mandarin l'anglais
l'espagnol et le indy le français est la
langue officielle dans 13 pays dont la
france mais aussi plusieurs pays
africains les la langue qu officielle
dans seize pays dont le canada et la
belgique
pour le moment la majorité des
francophones se retrouve en europe de
l'ouest mais des projections
démographiques indiquent qu'en 2050 85 %
des francophones seront africains
la journée de la francophonie est une
initiative de l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
l'oreille est fondée en 1970 regroupe 84
états membres ou observateurs
contrairement au common word la
francophonie est un club ouvert dans la
moitié des états qui le composent
le français n'a aucun statut officiel
cette ouverture est un choix politique
de la france le principal bailleur de
fonds de l'organisation en signant des
accords pour l'enseignement du français
dans des écoles de l'albanie de
l'arménie ou du qatar la france espère
contrecarrer l'hégémonie de l'anglais
dans le monde
[Musique]